bonjour à tous je m'appelle sommes
proches et je suis ravi et très fier
d'avoir été investi par les républicains
sur la première circonscription du rhône
pour les prochaines élections
législatives de juin prochain vous avez
deviné je suis à lyon et je suis très
fier de vous accueillir dans cette ville
je suis né où j'ai étudié et où j'écris
rivière va sans mon entreprise de
tourisme événementiel qui me permet
d'être très proche de tous nos acteurs
économiques est il ou de terrain je suis
en responsabilité et en toute dignité
puisque je dois faire face chaque jour à
une majorité absolue et dogmatique et
punitive qui tient la ville il se trouve
que nous sommes dans la région auvergne
rhône alpes lyon et dans la capitale de
cette région aux forces engagées très
puissante aussi formatrice et
intervenante dans des écoles supérieures
je suis attaché à la transmission et
souhaite par l'éducation assurer
l'avenir de la jeunesse et favoriser
leur liberté d'entreprendre élus de la
nation je défendrai le pouvoir d'achat
de nos concitoyens
ce serait bien sûr attentive à la bonne
gestion de l'argent public
et comme je suis quelqu'un de déterminé
franche des gens est très attentive à
leur sécurité je la leur garantir l
consciente que la santé a été oublié
j'agirai pour refonder notre système de
santé et pour reconquérir notre
souveraineté sanitaires
l'écologie est pour moi très important
ne la laissons pas simplement à la
gauche la protection de l'environnement
et aussi notre rôle je reste engagé avec
les républicains je suis toujours fidèle
à ce groupe même si le navire est dans
la tempête et bastide je suis toujours
présente et je transmets les valeurs
républicaines haut les coeurs ensemble
soyons les plus forts